[Music]
Leader surfer Welcome to
the new world, everyone, together with us, we will bring out the world of dreams
First of all, it's a funny clown, yeah
It's raining all three
[Music]
me
rar
[Laughter]
[Applause]  ]
Hey, hey,
what are you doing?
That color
was a member of the circus after all
When I heard the rumor that the circus was coming to this town, I thought maybe it was
[music]
Higashi  It's the same with people, is
n't it? I think many of the other people who are here now also came here thinking the same thing.
]
Well then, take the next one and don't cry I'll take you to the horse tightrope walker three steps
down If you make a good joke, it's the end
Well, everyone, luckily, the place where you pushed the Restoration wasn't your group.